you've talked to alex jones a couple
days ago sure yeah we've talked to him
many times before but you've had him on
your podcast
um this week yeah this week i was kind
of surprised that um
he mentioned that human animal hybrids
was like
the number the main conspiracy that
people should
look into to open their eyes to the
you know to the globalists to all the
conspiracies that are out there
was that surprising to you um no
because i came in there with questions
and i was very focused on corralling him
and having it be
like a kind of a coherent intellectual
conversation that was a really really
good it was only an hour but it was a
very good conversation yeah thank you i
i
i the response was overwhelmingly
positive and i'm like all right
i'm in a unique position because alex i
i met alex well that's not true but i
was on alex
with alex on tim pool a couple of times
it was mayhem
it was anarchy and i'm like all right
let me get but the thing is what people
enjoyed is i was the one who was
basically
able to translate alex ease he's
obviously very performative
and a lot of times alex will say things
that are not really
uh particularly controversial but he'll
say them in such a way
that it sounds crazier than it is you
know i think joe's made this observation
as well
so what i wanted to have him on when on
my show
is all right let's go through all these
conspiracies
which have validity which don't and i
knew if i asked because he's got a lot
of historical knowledge even if you want
to think of a lot of it's nonsensical
let's sort out the wheat from the chaff
you know
because everyone has someone crazy in
them i have this expression
you take one red pill not the whole
bottle you take the whole bottle of red
pills you assume literally everything in
the media is a lie
that that's just not a coherent position
to have is the weather a lie when they
tell you the
temperature is gonna be wrong tomorrow
so that was fun to watch him go through
that
and he felt bad because he felt
incorrectly in my opinion
that he was needlessly aggressive and
disrespectful toward me on tim i didn't
feel disrespected at all it got heated
but i didn't take it personally people
have heated debates all the time
so i think he he promised me he wouldn't
interrupt and would be deferential
but that because he promised to be on
his best behavior
that gave me an opportunity to address
him seriously
and not to bring the clown aspect out of
him which is easy to caricature him
my friend ethan supply um who i'm sure
people know played basically character
based on him in the hunt
because eric alex is kind of this
cartoon archetype so
it was really fun to get another side of
him um
and and also it's just fun being on his
show just him being bombastic and
just trying to be the calm voice of
reason and for once the trickster was
apollo
well i like this this thing he said
before
and that's what makes me the most
interested in alex
is the uh the nietzsche quote about the
uh you know oh yeah
gazing into the abyss i think he said on
your show that he has become the abyss
or something like that
i think that makes him fascinating that
when you really take conspiracy theories
seriously
the kind of effect it has on your mind
that to me is fascinating well can i say
one thing
the term conspiracy theory if you ask
any layman like
it's like this you say do you like
puppies i hate them do you like baby
dogs oh they're the best right people
the human mind is capable of doing this
yes so if you ask people
do you think extremely powerful people
often get together and manipulate data
or rules
in order to further their power and
control and maintain it i think 90 plus
percent of people be like of of course
then you say oh so you believe in
conspiracy theories oh no that's for
crazy people
those concepts are identical now that
term
is used for people who are like all
right uh um
you know there's conspiracies in
government to experiment on people like
tuskegee this is not in dispute the cia
has you know unsealed things operation
mockingbird so on and so forth
and at the same time conspiracy theory
applies to people who say
911 never happened and those were
holograms now it's the same word for
both
but these are not at all equal truth
claims and they do not at all have equal
evidence to them
but it's very useful for powerful people
to have that term in the zeitgeist
because then i don't have to explain or
defend it's like only lunatics are going
to look further on this
do you really want to be a lunatic kid
and that takes care of the issue
unfortunately the same problem applies
with language applies to a lot of other
100 that's the nature of language yeah
it's used not just to communicate but to
obfuscate
obviously that could be fixed by coming
up with different words
to uh to label conspiracy theories that
are much more
likely to be true yeah power elite
analysis is another is basically
conspiracy theory
this is the black pill versus white pill
question sure with the abyss
do you think thinking about these things
can can destroy the mind
can uh make you deeply cynical about the
world
yeah because if you are thinking that
you are not aware of or
no one is aware of who's controlling
things
and that the level of their control it
gives you the sense of powerlessness and
hopelessness
yeah and my counter is the people in
charge
one of the reasons i'm an anarchist are
nowhere near as smart and crafty as you
think they are
and certainly maybe the the ones
completing the shadow maybe are but the
ones who are
in the public face most certainly are
not as social media has demonstrated
when you look at how senators and
harvard professors tweet
these are not you know intellects that
you're in awe of to put it mildly
so i think that kind of takes the bloom
off the rose to a great extent
you